جدل جديد في الكويت سوق شرق من اشهر
المجمعات التجاريه في الكويت تستثمره شركه
الوطنيه العقاريه عام 2019 انتهى عقد
استثمار سوق شرق وطلبه شركه تجديده ولكن
القضيه ظلت عالقه حتى يوم الامس حيث رفضت
الشركه المشغله تسليم السوق
العقد غير قابل للتجديد وان المبالغ
المستلمه ليست الا جزءا من مستحقات سابقه
على الشركه لصالح الوزاره كما كشفت
الماليه ان قرار اخلاء سوق شرق يطبق على
المستثمر فقط ولا يشمل المؤيرين ما يعني
ان المتاجر مستمره في اعمالها دون تغيير
لحين تسليم السوق لشركه مشغله جديده بعد
مزايده علنيه ووسط الجدل الدائر بين
الماليه والشركه المشغله علت اصوات كثيره
ابدت تخوفها من قرار يقضي بازاله السوق او
تغيير هويته في وقت لم تبدي الجهات
المعنيه اينيه لازاله السوق